[Music]
[Music]
well guys
we've had a couple of problems with this
uh next episode nothing nothing to worry
about just technical problems but um
we we have done what we could to make it
as good as we can i think that's a great
way to explain it dude the interview
that you did with casper was so great
bill yeah but unfortunately because i
was in yosemite which i think some
people call yosemite right you also
might yeah yes i might um
the
feed my video and my audio isn't great
but billy's in the studio with casper
and billy is generally asking most of
the questions so i don't think you guys
are missing out on that much oh my
wonderful shiny face but we'll work out
as best as we can so please enjoy this
episode of the french onion
dom here we are another week done and
dusted but we're in slightly different
parts of um
the united states well you're in the
normal place i'm in your center
i'm actually in my normal seat my normal
chair but when i look to my right
normally dominic monahan is sitting
there
but he's not here he does not care i am
here i'm over there so you are you're in
yosemite how is it over there what's it
like tom tell me it's amazing i've never
been here before so
we we have a friend who came into town
he and his wife only have a week to
spare
they wanted to get out of l.a none of us
had ever been to yosemite before it's
stunning it's incredible you can
understand how
ansel adams came up here and just kind
of thought right well i'm gonna i need
to document these
um these sites because everywhere you
look is like a postcard the weather's
been amazing
yeah it's beautiful stunning up here
good stuff mate lovely climb one of
those trees they're quite high you know
we've been we've been considering doing
a little bit of free soloing but i don't
think we're going to get around to it
today because we're a little bit busy
maybe tomorrow we're going to go to the
sequoia trees um i'll i'll keep you
posted and what about you you're in la
anything to report what's been going on
ah much the same time much the same it's
getting warmer
so that's that's quite nice i like the
hot weather
so i got my shorts on got my legs out
that was nice
and uh
yeah it's been a good week but not not
not too much to report tom so how about
a little bit of housekeeping before we
get our guests on we have a guest this
week tom we have a guest this week an
amazing guest this week yes uh
yeah let's see let's see what's going on
in the housekeeping department now we
have a question here right another um
little comment here carry on job from
rod in gothenburg about doom patrol that
amazing show that you were on
to video bitterly deeply and um
love the show with a regular listener
since its inception just wanted to say
that i really loved the episode with
corey olson yeah we did too i always
enjoy listening to you guys just hanging
out i really love hearing you talk about
movies
acting about sci-fi and complete about
mulderings that's about it keep the
goodness coming p.s it was great seeing
billy as samuel son on season three of
doom patrol was that as much fun to make
as it was to watch we'd love to hear
more billy tell us about your facial
prosthetic experience i'll tell you what
tom i love i love these prosthetic guys
i love
the design
well straight off i love doom patrol i
think it's such a weird and wonderful
show
and and
great characters and they asked me to do
the the samuelson character and i
thought yeah and they showed me some
images of what they wanted to do and i
thought it's really fun to see what
these guys
how how they create you and these other
beings you know so i met the guys
and you know they're they're fantastic
the award-winning uh prosthetic guys and
they sit me down and they put all these
extra pieces on your head you know it
changed your head shape
but it's all just you know white color
and they get rid of all the lines
and then
they decided it was going to be a red
alien so i had to be completely painted
red
and then
with red eye things in as well i mean
it's amazing but one thing about that
character that they didn't think about
and it's exactly the same problem they
had on lauder rings with us with the
hobbit ears
they didn't think about us hearing right
do you remember when we first got the
hobbit ears for like a couple of weeks
the four of us couldn't hear anyone do
you remember that i do yeah they had to
cut little tiny holes in the bed yeah
exactly so they cut the the inside of
the ears off to help us unload the rings
but with samuelson the ear was in a
different place
because i'm an alien
obviously my ears are not where human
ears are right so they did cut a little
hole but it wasn't near my ears and
because of the red eyes as well i spent
the whole day not being able to see
anyone or hear anyone it was the
weirdest like kind of experience
but
the guys do such a beautiful job on it
you don't want to say well completely
change this so that i can hear
so and because it was it wasn't a you
know it wasn't as if we were there for
two years i thought i'll just i'll just
sit on a chair and not listen to anyone
but uh yeah the guys did a fantastic job
on that yeah it looks great it looks
really great you can kind of see that
it's you but also it's not it's not
super clear that it's used so obviously
all the all the stuff that they put you
in looks fantastic because
you do look like an alien creature yeah
it's brilliant and i i've always i don't
know about you dom but i always love
that
even if it's not a full prosthetic even
if it's costume
or anything like that where it helps
your character you know you maybe you're
struggling with trying to think how do i
play this guy or and someone just gives
you the perfect costume and you go oh
yeah i get it or like with these
prosthetics as soon as you're this alien
and weird eyes you start to kind of hold
yourself a different way and you find
the character that way you know
sweet very cool all right well we do
have another i know we have an amazing
guest yeah do you have a couple of other
letters if you're interested in well
shall we do one more and then we'll get
the guests on we're going to talk about
maple syrup or we can continue to add uh
swear words in the lord of the rings
swear words please dom what do you think
of this one tom
this is from megan and saint louis they
don't say saint louis i don't think i
think say st louis
at the end of the fellowship when
aragorn gimli and legolas are getting
ready to go after the orcs and rescue
mary and the very beautiful pippin
aragorn says
leave everything you can we travel late
let's hunt some fox i think that sits in
the category of things that could
actually have been said like you know
he's in that kind of headspace one here
from jenny graham in jackson wyoming
here's a quick suggestion on where to
insert a swear word in the trilogy when
arwyn crosses the river with frodo in
the fellowship of the thing she says to
the national if you want him come and
find
him
i think it works i think live would be
good at that actually
dom so we bring in our wonderful guest
this week let's do it
this is the leader of the tolkien
ensemble and i'll tell you about this
though
the tolkien ensemble founded in 1995
is a danish ensemble which successfully
aimed to create the world's first
complete musical interpretation of all
the poems and songs from the lord of the
rings they published four cds from 1997
to 2005 in which all the poems and songs
of the lauder rings are set to music
composer casper life
founded the token ensemble in copenhagen
in autumn 1995. at the time life was
studying guitar at the royal danish
academy of music in copenhagen he formed
an ensemble consisting of fellow
students from the academy and his former
guitar teacher the composer and musician
peter hall and they did it they put all
the music
all the poems and songs of lauder rings
to music well done casper life and
welcome to the friendship onion thank
you very much billy thank you
thanks
so let's let's start with that i think
casper i think um
so you you are at college you're at the
academy
um in in um in copenhagen the the music
academy
and you come up with this idea
yes
i read the books of course right when
did you read the books yeah
i read the books and and um
i've read them
actually
just around when i when i was um
getting ready to be to the application
for the academy of music ah
which was kind of confusing at that
moment because at that time guitar was
everything for me it was like
eight to
eight till eight every day
um just playing guitar and this book
came in you know and i was like all of a
sudden reading instead of playing okay
and i had a small concert in a small
danish church and i just had to read so
i didn't practice and everything just
turned out to be a total disaster and i
couldn't play the thing because all the
time i was thinking oh gandalf just died
and
so yeah but
it was obvious that these poems that are
described as songs in the lord of the
rings books
should have some music and um i went to
the
you know the the
music stores around copenhagen
but there was nothing there
um
so you're reading these poems uh
sometimes it's so it's say bilbo sings a
song yeah and now you wanted to hear the
song yeah and i was sure that some
somebody might i mean this was the
second best-selling book in the world at
the time out just after the bible wow
and how come that there was no music and
and
so i just started to make the music
myself
basically right a couple of tunes and
and thought
sounds pretty good
so
um
so that was the start of it and i
applied for the academy of music and
started
you know
attending the the
the academy as a classical guitarist and
then at the same time it constantly had
this idea
how how would how basically how would
this the music of middle earth sound
yeah yeah what kind of music history
would would would the various
characters have or the very various
people of middle earth okay like what
development at what development
would for instance the hobbit would
obviously be focus focus style yeah
um and all the clues are actually in the
in the poems the way tolkien wrote them
you know it's very obvious the drinking
songs of the hobbits and so on
and and then the the human would be kind
of a classical classical style here to
me and then the elves would be something
in between
yeah and the various characters like
gollum tree beard
would sort of take something from
everything
you know sure yeah and um
that was basically the the idea was to
to create a a
trustworthy music musical history of
middle earth but did you did you start
saying like how how many poems are in
louder rings
we got 69
so there's 69 there's 69 of them yeah
did you start thinking i'm going to do
this i'm going to do all of them or did
you just sit and say oh there's the
drinking song i want to put some music
to this or
i'm very much a completist right okay
and and and i i just wanted to do it all
in in order to do the music history of
middle earth
or or some some kind of music that would
you would have to make it all
right because
so so i knew from the beginning it would
be it would be a long project yeah and
it would be very
hard to finance it we were nerds back
then before the movies before you came
in and make us made us all pop stars
right
and you really made us very popular when
you made the movie so thank you very
much but before that we had only sold in
five years we sold about 2 000 cds
worldwide
before the movies yeah and and and when
you came along
it exploded of course because then
people said yeah anything lord of the
rings was was
people wanted to buy
two out of three men will experience
some sort of hair loss at a time of
35. more than 50 million men in the us
suffer from male pattern boldness
keeps
is the way forward
keeps us get more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors
there's only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps
offers both of them
keeps offers a simple
affordable and stress-free way to keep
your hair
it's convenient
virtual doctor consultations and
medications delivered straight to your
door every three months you don't have
to leave your house
24 7 care and support keeps has a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality
keeps is everything that your hair needs
delivered straight to your door with
discreet packaging
and proven results
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to
k e e p s dot com slash onion to receive
your first month of treatment
for free
that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash onion to get your first
month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash onion
today's episode is sponsored by honey
now
how do you like online shopping it makes
things pretty easy right
but how often do you get to the checkout
and you've got the right promo code to
save yourself some money probably like
me virtually never
but thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is now a thing of the
past
honey
is the free shopping tool that scours
the internet for promo codes and applies
the best one
right to your cat
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
tech
gaming
fashion
even food delivery they'll find the code
to save you money
so imagine you're shopping on one of
your favorite sites when you get to the
checkout the honey button drops down and
all you have to do is press
apply coupons wait a few seconds honey
searches for coupons finds the best one
for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon
you watch the prices drop i love it
i was looking for a a camera a battery a
new battery for my camera and i found
one press the honey button saved me a
lot of money
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out it's
literally free and installs in a few
seconds and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast
i'd never recommend something that i
don't use
get honey for free
at joinhoney.com
onion
that's joinhoney.com
so so you're you're at the college now
you're you're in copenhagen but you have
this idea
of of
doing all this music
so
do you get friends involved do you still
feel like well i'll finish
did you finish at college did you finish
your degree nope i i i was
i was a tolkien dropout
did you you dropped out for this idea
basically i got so much work with this
that um
and i i lost the motivation of of of
practicing classical guitar right okay
and then i just wanted to follow this
dream and took all the time i i had um
and the the problem was we
we started out yes i i had some friends
from the academy just joining me to play
this music
and we did that for about a year and
then we wanted to make the first cd of
it and suddenly realized we we had no
permission to do so
so we we of course um
and i kind of panicked because
everything was ready and
i i'd never thought about it really so
we
oh i gathered a lot of information and
all the
the music and so on and sent it to
harper collins publishers to contact the
talking estate the tolkien family
and realized they hadn't they hadn't
given that this permission for 20
23 years since
since tolkien's death so you've already
written a lot of the music the music a
lot of the music was already ready at
that at that time and then you thought
oh wait a minute i might not be allowed
to do this yeah exactly and and i was
told by david braun on harper collins
publishers
don't raise your hopes you know they've
always said no
but unfortunately
they they liked what we did and
after a couple of months they i got the
permission to go on with the project
which was fantastic and of course you
know
life-changing thing for me
was it as simple as that you just sent
them the music did you did you meet
anyone from the tolkien family or later
on later on i i had a letter from
priscilla tolkien tolkien's daughter and
she invited me to
to come and and perform music in her
house in oxford she recently died
yeah yeah yeah
and she she became the galatrial of my
project because she always
sort of protected me when whatever
happened you know because she really
liked the way we did it right peter hall
and i
um she liked the style and
and um i remember once i came up to her
house and me and my wife were there we
were
20 minutes early
and um
it was raining so we knocked on the door
anyways
and um
it was supposed to be this talking
society gathering there and we were 20
minutes early and she said oh do come in
casper you are family now
what more could you want
you're in the talkie in fact yeah she
said so yeah she's a very she was a very
almost as polite as you are billy
or dom
well that's that's amazing so you've
made so then you've made the first
cd
then we made the first cd
and it was a
very nice experience good reviews also
internationally
on a small danish label uh-huh um
sold nothing
basically and then we did the the other
one
the second album
in 2000
um and then
the third album we we have the that we
we brought in christopher lee sir
christopher lee on the on the third
album and that's sort of when i i heard
about your you guys and i heard some of
the music probably through christopher
leah thing actually i think he probably
played some of it
um
he was he was reading poetry on it
correct
he he he read poetry and and i had conte
i i'd sent him a letter when he when you
maybe you were there too at the gala
premiere in copenhagen for the first
movie
the fellowship of the ring i think i
think what i think
i think vigo went because he
has the whole
background of um
of
denmark so i think it was viggo and
bernard hill because i remember bernard
said he that was his favorite
at that time he just thought he had a
great time in denmark whatever you guys
were all up to i don't know
but um so so
christopher lee was there as well
christopher lee was there and i thought
there was these about 20 poems that
should be rather
read and it should not be this kind of
you know
most of us talk this kind of um upper
english
you know yeah yeah so it should be the
right thing and and he was in town so i
got a letter to him at the hotel and he
called me back
and said
what is that you want want me to do for
you
and i told him i wanted him to read
aloud these poems and so on and he said
i can do that how did you get a letter
to him just wrote it one of the one of
the pr pr the marketing ladies from
scandinavian phil company just handed it
over to him and then he said
do you know i'm a singer
and i said no i didn't know that and
would you like to sing and yes he would
like to do that and i said well you
could be three beard in our project
um and then amazingly enough he said
he he started just quoting from directly
from the poem of tribute song
in the willow meets of tasarinan i
walked in the spring
like that just with my heart just by
heart
and
then we peter hall made a melody and i
arranged it and we
two months later we recorded with
christopher lee in copenhagen and that
of course changed a lot for us as well
having this
major
major character on our recordings yeah
so
and and and for people who don't know
christopher lee was a huge token fan
long before the movies he
he read it every year uh after he he had
read that he'd met tolkien
i mean just a huge fan so i'm sure when
you guys got in touch with him with the
the passion that you you guys have and a
real
love of the stories that he he could see
that there wasn't uh
a throwaway project that this was
something coming from a very real he
really loved it and he loved he loved
singing
and
and he he one of the one of his maybe
great his greatest passion was actually
classical music right and and my full
band was basically classical musicians
so he loved you know dining with us and
talking about old tenors from the 60s
and we all knew them so we could
actually discuss these things with him
and he found that totally amazingly
enjoyable so yeah so for him it had been
great talking about all these uh
classical musicians with you and all
conductors you know yeah
you guys would know yeah he wouldn't be
able to talk to with other people no no
no and then for you guys you're sitting
with christopher lee yeah and we was of
course we we asked a lot about
his life and what's going on in star
wars at the moment because he was in
both trilogies at the time i met him of
course he was in both star wars and lord
of the rings
and um
he just wanted to talk about classical
music i asked him once
oh i just said well i would i would have
loved to be a part of star wars and lord
of the rings i would much rather do that
than playing the piano and he said
well i don't know
oh really yeah so he really he had the
chance of being a singer when he was
young but he had he couldn't afford
to to pay
the teaching forward and so on it's a
difficult time
i have a question for casper
i think we we were talking earlier on
about the fact that there was um
a total of 69 poems in lord of the rings
that tolkien had written
you did you start with a particular one
for a reason like was there one that
seemed to be more
like a song than any of the others or
like which was the first one that you
attacked
yeah the the one that that billy is
going to sing in a moment
which is which is actually one of the
it's the only song that's represented
three times in the lord of the rings and
sung twice by bilbo and once by frodo
with every time with with changes in the
words
so so you have um so that was the and it
was an easy one to i mean anybody could
write a melody for for that one and it's
also the one that they used in the
beginning of a lot of the rings gandalf
sings it like this something like
the road goes
from the door
picture and sort of and we we did our
melody before that and it's more slow
and so on it's more
longing in a sense that's it's not as
foolish
but um that i think that was the first
one and then collateral song after that
but it was it wasn't planned like just
it was just like which ones
is just which one is inspired most at
the time
well if we are going to play something i
i will have to i will have to borrow
your book because unlike christopher lee
i don't know all the words of lord of
the rings
um yeah shame on you brilliant right you
know what i mean
but do you remember christopher lee er
we
the the four hobbits shared a makeup
trailer all through the
the trilogy
and
at some times so it was like the makeup
trailer had four chairs and then there
was a little sort of door and another
chair and gandalf was in there a lot of
the time
really annoyed us because we would play
music really loud and annoying so he
would close that little door and be
annoyed at the four hobbits as as
gandalf should be but when sarro man
arrived he took that chair for quite
some time probably ian thought oh if i
can get out of here that'd be great
but rather than be annoyed by it he
loved the music
and we we would take uh days each
so one day you know dom would come in
and put on the stone roses and the next
day i would come in and put on you know
the proclaimers and and then elijah
would choose something weird
and then um
christopher lee joined in on that so he
had a day when he would play music and
it was very often either something
classical or something he's singing or
something incredibly heavy like heavy
metal yeah but he's singing heavy metal
yeah yeah do you remember them
yeah he was very big on heavy metal that
seems to be the genre that he wanted to
impress
on us the most maybe because we were
young men i mean i do remember a couple
of classical moments but generally
classical music can be a little
quiet to listen to in a little subtle
and we were always playing loud stuff
and i remember us all being so
impressed that like billy said not only
did he keep his door open but he was
actively engaged in like oh which
radiohead album is that and he you know
he'd like to make notes and stuff so a
very impressive human christopher lee
and i both saw him throw a pen into a
tree as well which was really impressive
tell that story what a guy he threw a
pen
we would sit around on set in some some
area of
who's on location some some part of new
zealand south island may be around at
the time where
the fellowship is breaking up just after
em on hen
and i don't know elijah and i just found
ourselves sat on those kind of classical
high actor chairs christopher lee was
with us
and we were talking about nothing in
particular and an a.d war passed and
christopher lee says you know excuse me
do you have a pen
and they gave christopher lee just like
a normal buy room and you know he kind
of said
watch this type thing and then just
threw it like a knife
and it lodged in the tree like a weapon
and obviously christopher lee was
trained
in the special forces and you know we
kind of thought well if you can do that
with a pen
how can he do it with a knife he was a
very impressive human being
one time we would do these really long
press junkets you know days and days of
sitting on chairs like this and people
coming in from different channels
and having six minutes or four minutes
or two minutes to do a quick interview
and then they would leave
so that they have for their channel
an exclusive interview and i was always
with dom normally or the four hobbits or
you know it was always like that
and for what one day for some reason
they put me with christopher lee i don't
know why i mean pippin and it didn't
make any sense to me but i sat there
and i basically didn't see anything
because i was amazed by this guy
people would come in from france
and he would speak to them in french
and then they'd come in from germany
he'd speak in german
danish i was just like this guy is
unbelievable it was it was type of human
he was really
i was in in the slipstream of
christopher lee for many years also
doing some the same kind of stuff
just in the music business
and um
we were doing promotion in london at the
time and and then we were supposed to go
to the
hilton hotel to have some afternoon tea
between two interviews right and uh
christopher lee always liked to drink
schnapps you know snaps
dumb do you know snaps
yeah i know schnatt's a little um
do you know it right do you know the
norwegian lineage
yeah
sounds good though no
but it's it's it's it's a brand and what
they're special what's special about
them is that they're making this
schnapps which is like vodka just a
scandinavian way of doing it
and then
they they sail it all across the planet
and just sell it when it's been all
around the planet once
and that's what christopher lee always
wanted so everybody for what reason does
it make it more tasty does it make it
stronger that's what they say it's in a
barrel
it's the taste it should be the taste of
it that's that's special
splish splash
i was taking a bath
and after the bath i smelt fantastic and
i'll tell you why i was using the new
ultra premium collection from our
friends at manscape this new skin care
and hair care product lineup is designed
to upgrade
your shower routine your skin hair
armpits deserve only the best
but you can save big on these products
by going to manscape.com because you can
save 20
if you use our code onion
now let me tell you let me tell you what
what what you get with this new premium
collection the new ultra premium body
wash which i really love i think they've
got the smell bang on it's got aloe vera
seesaw makes your skin feel good then
you get your hair care you've got your
shampoo and conditioner in one is
fantastic i really
they've really nailed it with the smell
here get out of the shower you can um
you can
moisturize yourself
get your deodorant on
dry skin don't worry about that
put a wee bit of lip balm on after
you're done you're ready for the day and
the good thing is the people at
landscape have made all this stuff
cruelty free it's paraben free it's dye
free and it's vegan it's really
brilliant and a really lovely cologne
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code onion manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code onion at
manscape.com it's time to get wet and
clean with your new manscaped
shower routine
now we all like cereal who doesn't like
cereal but we all know now that it's not
very good for you it's got way too much
sugar in it it's got all sorts of other
additives and things that we shouldn't
be eating but i tell you who makes a
cereal that you can eat and still feel
good
magic spoon
magic spoon cereal is very healthy and
it tastes fantastic
and another thing it holds off cravings
since i've been eating it in the morning
i notice i don't have any cravings right
through to lunch it's really good stuff
here's some facts
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein that's a lot of protein that's a
good thing and only four net grams of
carbs in each serving only 140 calories
per serving it's keto friendly it's
gluten free grain free soy free and it's
low carb
build your own box
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle are cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter cookies and cream maple
waffle blueberry cinnamon plus
the newly formulated
honey nut flavor that will be added to
magic spoons permanent collection and i
love that one it is fantastic so go to
magicspoon.com onion to grab a custom
bundle of cereal and be sure to use our
promo code onion at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
so uh always when when he came to
denmark denmark he said the casper can
you make sure there's a bottle of linea
on my hotel room and i always made sure
so we come in to the so we go into the
hilton hotel
and he walks up to the bar and says i
would like a linear exhibit
and no nobody knows in england in london
what linear kirby is so so
and you know the the bartender that they
kind of panicked and they asked me what
is schnapps and and i told them it's
kind of a vodka and they came with the
up with the with the vodka card which is
was 200 different vodkas he couldn't
choose and he was just annoyed so he
just said i'll have a beer then
none of those no no linear create or
just a beer i don't think i could even
say that linhya linda
linea
yeah
very close
now
casper can we talk about this lovely
book because i don't know if you know
but i'm one of the great book binders in
all the world and as soon as as soon as
you hand me this this is a beautifully
bound book
um
the lord of the rings it has on here
the token ensemble
and casper leaf it is yeah so uh
have you got a story behind why you have
such a beautifully bound lord of the
rings it is actually really beautiful
it's because you've signed it
[Laughter]
no it isn't it's because that's that's a
working lord of the rings um edition
that we
used in the studio so we have all the
notes there
and then also i i've had some
very nice people like um dom and you
sign it and so on over the years
who's this and two beautiful drawings
sidney smith made that one
wonderful the canadian artist wonderful
person and a wonderful artist and yeah
so that's my who burned it that was the
queen's book binder in denmark yeah
he's called
olsen and he is um
he is very very good and um i paid a lot
of money for it but and actually it's
just a cheap australian paperback that i
got from my girlfriend
when i was very young
and then he's put this and
and and very legendary it was broken in
two
the book was broken into like like
arrogant sword yeah
yeah
shall we have a go at this song shall we
yeah we shall and it's the old the old
walking song sure i just i just found a
picture of christopher lee yeah that's
and you and and the book and this is the
actual book
and the producer our producer morton
modern who oh i know
so this is um
this is a song um that billboard tell us
about this song before you guys begin
this is a little backstage you sang this
before billy i've i've never sang this
before no but it's um i know i know the
poem quite well
it's uh as
as um casper said it it
arrives three times in the book but i
think the first time is bilbo right this
is the first time it's this yes this is
big bomb
and um this is one of the first that you
wrote
from all the it must have been the first
one yeah and then i think so yeah and
it's got that famous line dom the road
goes ever on and on
like life right on right well one one
day it will stop but i'm not looking
forward to that before you guys begin
maybe casper can speak this a little bit
tolkien always seemed to be interested
not only in roads this idea of life
being seen as a kind of a road a journey
but the other thing that he talks about
which obviously he mentions in this is
that
it doesn't stop you know paths lead from
one way to another the road he's always
kind of meandering those that wander and
not lost that you know he's very much
interested in exploring
journeys and he and rhodes seem to
figure you know you have the hobbits
kind of walking on a road and then
leaving a road and then leaving a path
and
splitting the path
like that's an interesting theme in
tolkien's work right definitely
definitely and um
yeah that you know there's always a
point with with talking never does
anything without a point he used more
than 10 years to write this book
so
that this song is the is used three
times and that that the road theme is
basically
um
going through the book
is you're absolutely right there's a
point with that you know
yeah and um that is the you know the
life journey we all have you know and
we have to be courageous to to make it
and so on so i think at this part um at
this part gandalf um
bilbo has actually given the ring
to gandalf to give to frodo he he he
passes the ring on because he yeah he
it's exactly the point that he doesn't
give it to gandalf yeah because gandalf
don't want the ring because then gandalf
will be sauron yeah yeah but he's
leaving it with gandalf so that he can
leave it with frodo so it's a huge
moment in bilbo's life absolutely and
the first two to actually surrender the
ring free of free will yeah and this is
a a long expected party yeah
okay shall we uh yeah and we do the
introduction to the song as well yeah
yeah yeah
it was a fine night
and the black sky was dotted with stars
he looked up sniffing the air what fun
what fun to be off again off on the road
with dwarves this is what i have really
been longing for for years goodbye he
said looking at his old home
and bowing to the door
goodbye gandalf
goodbye for the present bilbo take care
of yourself you are old enough and
perhaps wise enough
take care i don't care don't you worry
about me i am as happy now as i have
ever been and that is saying a great
deal
but the time has come and i am being
swept off my feet at last he added and
then in a low voice as if to himself
he sang softly in the dark
the road
goes ever on and on
down from the door
where it began
now far
ahead the road has
and i
must follow if i can
pursuing it
with ecruffy
until it joins some large away
[Music]
the road
[Music]
and i must follow if i can
lovely stuff casper
lovely loving lovely wonderful lovely
bilbo isn't he just the sweetest
you know when i first read the hobbit
uh
i was i was so taken by bilbo
that i couldn't read lord of the rings
once it became frodo's story i was like
where's bilbo where's bilbo and i
stopped reading it yeah but
i started with law of the rings so to me
it was a surprise that bilbo has such an
such a big role in in
in the hobbit you know i i think i kind
of got it totally wrong you know i i
took it lord of the rings the hobbit the
silmarillion that's backwards yes so
but that's that's all
modern people will be doing it now
because of peter jackson's movies right
probably they they sort of um would do
it that way what about you dom did you
did you do it the right order
start with the silmarillion
to the end of the lord of the rings no i
i kindly did it like
billy i listened to the bbc
radio play of the hobbit
drive my parents obviously driving me
backwards and forwards from germany to
england
once or twice a year so like billy i
thought bilbo and gandalf were kind of
the main stars and then when i went red
rings much later
in my kind of mid-teens
i was the same i was kind of flicking
through the first i don't know
100 pages of the book and realizing that
bilbo featured kind of at the start of
all the rings but then once they left
the shire
i was like oh i guess it's not about
bilbo and then very quickly realized
that frodo has his own kind of
deep uh prisoner and stuff but um
i think maybe because the hobbit
as a book
is slightly more geared towards kids or
or a younger reader i found it a little
bit easier to access and then lord riggs
is clearly quite a
you know quite a task to
read but um yeah kind of kind of similar
to really yeah um but i wanted to ask
you guys so obviously you guys have met
because you guys have got together and
worked together in a music fashion but i
don't know if the i don't know if the
listeners know about that yet so maybe
you guys can just talk about
those those ways that you guys have met
across europe and work together
absolutely so that that sort of came
from christopher lee as well right
krista you and christoph elite did some
concerts with this wonderful music
and
um
sadly of course christopher lee passed
and
yes we
at in the talking sound we've worked for
25 years now 27 years now i think
and
we've done concerts
first we started out as a small group
only seven people
performing
and gradually especially after we
finished the recording project and the
movies came around and so on
we we started to combine our music with
with also our own arrangements of of
howard shows music
and
doing live concerts with christopher lee
from time to time not not every time but
so we started out i was called in
2004 i think it was if i wanted to join
christopher lee for a concert in holland
and
we did that sold out amazing concert
with christopher lee on stage for three
hours and
and uh
it sort of went on from there to to a
lot of of international shows also
featuring
john callan one of the one of i think he
played
one of the he played one of the dwarfs i
don't really remember which one of them
and then
all of a sudden billy came along and the
fantastic thing about working with billy
is that billy is a musician as well so
he has his own original music
in this middle earth thing with the last
goodbye and edge of knight and so on um
so that was a fantastic thing maybe one
of the
that's a great pleasure to work with you
really and and it's a combination of
token and sample and and billy's own
thing and
and um
[Music]
so so yes and so we've done about almost
100 concerts together billy now and as
as uh casper has been um in town for
this week we have talked and we think
we're going to be doing another showdom
and uh we we may write something in
there for you um something wonderful but
you will need to be naked that's fine
i'm okay with that you know me
no problem i'd love that yeah but it's
great and um
yes it's just fun it's just great fun
and wow
and and you know this world of tolkien
dom you know
as well as anyone that the passion that
it brings and and when it when it leads
to something like this you know
an incredible body of work that you've
done i've heard it played with
orchestras and it's it's beautiful and
i've seen it played as a small kind of
you know not a folk group but
with really interesting instruments and
you know what the tolkien inspires that
is just wonderful and you see all over
the world like people who have made you
know
um costumes uniforms that have been
inspired by tolkien the map maker and
just how
those stories of just info and so many
people it's totally amazing and and all
these fantastic musicians you know i
mean it's sharon
enya
yeah any landmarks
real finn wonderful all kinds of and how
it shows wonderful
movie music i mean it's it's there's so
much fantastic music so we we
will go on and
i think that's that's my life doing this
it's it's just my life doing
music of middle earth can you
can you put your finger on why
when you read the book you said this is
it
this is this is what um
maybe not at that time but you end up
making your life about
that world that world of talking middle
earth was there something in the story
i mean to it's almost like why why did
you become an actor you know i mean
you know like oh well maybe yeah i mean
it's it was such a big thing for me it's
just like i have to the problem if it
would have been a major problem and it's
very interesting for me to think back if
we did not receive the permission from
the tolkien family yeah what would i
have done what would i i have become
maybe a classical guitarist whatever um
going that but i don't think that would
have been
the the amazing thing about being in
lord of the rings business is is it goes
from
you know the most nerdish fan base
to the highest
um
commercial
you know yeah things like it goes from
a nerdish guy just doing his own
drawings of it
and up to peter jackson doing
billions yeah
productions you know
international things
and that's that's so so there's always
that it's it's this big thing that you
can go into and it's very very
interesting and stimulating
in every way
wow hey
great music that last song seriously
it's fantastic you guys should bring
that out thanks very much christmas
number one or something like that
would you really yeah would how much
would you spend on it
is it a
um
what's on the b side
uh it's it's just me like humming mm-hmm
[Music]
four and a half dollars well that's not
bad yeah it's a yellow vinyl oh great
five bucks hey nice yeah that was great
that was the music's fantastic you know
you play the guitar i've seen you play
the guitar my brother's a great guitar
player
well i don't know i've ever seen someone
play the guitar like casper though
beautiful beautiful stuff great musician
and i just love that story i mean
just
to make that decision you know reading
those books i'm i'm i'm going to find
some of these songs what no one's
recording them i'm going to do them all
do them all isn't that great not only do
them all but do them so well that once
the tolkien estate
managed to hear about what they've done
they said we'd like to be
part of the official
uh
songs yeah given them given
don't give the rights to anyone no
brilliant great stuff well thank you
very much casper i love it really
wonderful that was fantastic um
we've run out of time yeah we'd love for
you guys to send us tongue twisters
because we love doing a tongue twister
or two
and obviously a riddle what else just
thought something brilliant
we'll ask casper to send us a tongue
twister from denmark oh in danish and
danish
because i mean just just trying to speak
danish is hard to a tongue tongue
twister that's going to be good but if
you've got any tongue twisters please
send them we love doing that if there's
any swear words that you think should
have been in-law the rings please send
those yeah yeah of course riddles yes if
there's any guests that you would like
to see on the friendship onion let us
know just send us an email to the
friendship onion at castmedia.com or
leave us a voicemail at speakpipe.com
forward slash the friendship onion my
particular favorite this week that
someone sent me on instagram which i
think we might have mentioned before is
when gandalf rolls up in his car
uh and sees frodo when he's entering the
shower shia and frodo says you're
um
we'll see you guys next week on the
friendship onion doodles bye
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host the baby you're my pearl
[Music]